why are women attracted to Bad Boys if
you have this particular dark Triad of
traits well there are two things so one
is that they do often have
characteristics that women do find
attractive in mates so these guys are
often very self-confident and they're
often risk-taking and so women find guys
who were Brave in the face of danger
willing to take risks physical risks or
social risks like telling a joke to an
entire room at a party is a social risk
but also physical risk driving
motorcycles these guys often have traits
that are attractive to women but they're
especially attractive to younger women I
think part of it is inexperience the
high dark Triad guys are disastrous as
long-term mates but they can be
sometimes very exciting as short-term
baits and sometimes younger women
they're the new in The Mating Market
they engage in experimentation some
experimentation as they mature get some
more experience they want to settle down
into a long-term committed makeshift and
the high dark Triad guys can be very
exciting and short-term baits but
disastrous as long-term mates